That brings me to another background technology that I have
to explain to you and which is called log structured
file system. The idea here is that when I make
a change to file y meaning I either append to
the file or make some modifications to it. What I'm
going to do is rather than writing the file as is,
I'm going to write the change that I made to
the file as a log record. So, I have a log
record that says, what are the changes I made to this file x. Similarly, I have
a log record of all the changes I made to this file y. And this is being done in
a data structure which I'll call log segment. And
I'll keep this log segment data structure in memory,
of course, to make it fast in terms of
the file system operation. So with this log segment
data structure, what I can do is, buffer
the changes to multiple files in one contiguous log
segment data structure. So this log segment data structure,
I can write it out as a file, and
when I write it out, I'm not writing a
single file, but I'm actually writing a log segment
which contains all the changes made to multiple files.
And because the log segment is contiguous, I can
write it sequentially on the disk and sequential writes
are good in the disk subsystem. And what we
want to do is, we want to gather these changes to
files that are happening in my system in the
log segment in memory, and every once in a
while, flush the log segment to disk, once the
log segment fills up to a certain extent, or
periodically. And the reason, of course, is the fact
that if it is in memory, you have to
worry about reliability of your file system, if, in fact,
the node crashes. And therefore, what we want to
do is, we want to either write out these log
segments periodically or when a lot of file activity
is happening and the log segment fills up very rapidly.
After it passes of threshold, then you write it
out to the desk. So in other words, we use
a space metric or a time metric to figure
out when to flush the changes from the log segment
into the disk. And this solves the small write
problem because if y happens to be a small file.
No problem, because we are not writing y as-is
on to the disk. But what we are writing is
this log segment that contains changes that have been
made to y in addition to changes that have been
made to a number of other files. And
therefore, this log segment is going to be a
big file. And therefore, we can use the RAID
technology to stripe the log segments across multiple disks.
And give the benefit of the parallel IO
that's possible with the RAID technology. So this log
structured file system solves the small write problem. And
in log structured file system, there are only logs.
No data files. You'll never write any data files.
All the things that you're writing are these append only
logs to the disk. And when you have a read of a file, the read of a file, if
it has to go to the disk and fetch
that file, then the file system has to reconstruct the
file from the logs that it has stored on the
disk. Of course, once it comes into the memory of
the server, then in the file cache the
file is going to remain as a file. But, if
at any point, the server has to fetch
the file from the disk, it's actually fetching the
log segments. And then reconstructing the file from
the log segments. That's important. Which means that, in
a log structured file system, there could be
latency associated with reading a file for the first
time from the disk. Of course, once it is read from
the disk and reconstructed, it is in memory. In the file
cache of the server, then everything is fine. But the first
time, you have to read it from the disk, it's going to
take some time because you have to read all these log
segments and reconstruct it and that's where parallel RAID technology can
be very helpful, because you're aggregating all the bandwidth that's available
for reading the log segments from multiple disks at the same time.
And the other thing that you have to worry about,
when you have a log structured file system, is that these
logs represent changes that have been made to the files.
So, for instance, I may have written a particular block of
y and that may be the change sitting here. Next
time, what I'm doing is perhaps I'm writing the same block
of the file. In which case, the first strike that I
did, that is invalid. I have got a new write of
that same block. So, you see that over time, the logs are going to have lots of
holes created by overwriting the same block of
a particular file. So in a log structured
file system, one of the things that has to happen is that the logs have to
be cleaned periodically to ensure that the disk
is not cluttered with wasted logs that have empty
holes in them because of old writes to
parts of a file that are no longer relevant.
Because those parts of the file have been
rewritten, overwritten by subsequent writes to the same file.
So logs, as I've introduced you, is similar
to the disks that you've seen in the DSM
system with the multiple writer protocol that we talked
about in a previous lecture. You may have also
heard the term, journalling file system, there is
a difference between log structured file system, and journalling
file system. Journalling file systems has both log files
as well as data files, and what a journalling
file system does, is it applies the log
files to the data files and discards the log
files. The goal is similar in a journaling file
system, and the goal is to solve the small
write problem, but in a journaling file system, the logs are there only for a
short duration of time before the logs
are committed to the data files themselves. Whereas
in a log structured file system, you don't have data files at all, all that
you have are log files and reads have
to deconstruct the data from the log files.